SLE playing between Kane and Hyman and it's
dle Wheeling his way in but turning the puck
over CC and nurse defensively meanwhile Pierre
angal away for the New York Islanders in a r
shot Off The Rush is stopped by Skinner as
is the rebound as pouring in he's Louis I'm
Jack we'll hear from Jean intermittently on
Rogers Monday night hockey as Skinner fights
off a shot from Romanov from distance rebound
whacked around the boards Maas at home up the
wall Nan Hopkins didn't get it out here's a drive
to score Matthew barzel opens the scoring just 40
seconds in the allers take a one- nothing lead
exactly what they do they come out after that
turnover into the Zone they come right into the
offensive zone save a couple of them by Skinner
but off this face off they go to work once again
and this is possession a couple of times you have
to win those battles and they don't that's a one
timer by Matt Marcel typically a shooter lets this
one go from the high slot right-handed shot winds
it up one- nothing out they've got nine guys who
played more than 400 games in the franchise C's
part of that identity line not tonight as Matt
Martin a healthy stratch and Julian go will get
an opportunity soken handles that the pass Ander
for horat and now it's a reset for Mattias e
you mentioned that relief Duty it was David
Quinn and staff and Rangers who were struck by
Co this KN block won his first game nine nothing
the Philadelphia Flyers you understand that
the longest 10e New York island are obviously
not happy with people that are jumping on the
team this early in the season barzel off the
draw and his shot was tied up and unlike Conor
McDavid and the injured Conor Brown he won an
Ontario Hockey League Championship with 2017
FEA one through out to board a blast the same
sokin who came way out to challenge the pestering
McDavid creates a turnover new Hopkins though had
have popped off his sticks s back fired s soken m
David could not find the rebound whacked off his
stick by Clutterbuck but maintained by Edmonton P
against mcdavis Newan Hopkins will toss it right
back to him McDavid challenging dishing shooting
and that might have glissing off the left goal
post it did he just Club it around d s one he
just missed what a look from Leon R that work
in the corners again is really paying off and
just finding ways to find that scene Drive CLE
score his six that's some side relief for him
and the ORS have forged a one- one deadlock
keep and pucks support beautiful back pass out
the corner by dry to set this in motion rander
great one timer on the transition we talked about
this quick up give the puck to a four with open
that's exactly what D does and that shot by
dry idle makes it look easy it hasn't been
this year but picks that spot a little Messier
like up over top of the pad under the blocker
1-1 nurse the that fired out and held in by Noah
doson turned over steel Warren foger little spin
move drop off McDavid shooting that stopped by
soken and he'll lunge and cover the rebound it's
Chance by Conor McDavid off the rush here it was
fogal in the defensive Zone after a couple quick
pressures and that's Again part of that playing
fast in the dzone turns the puck over save Soka
rebound to the middle of the ice head to Kane
shot and that whistled up high and ultimately
out of play 52 seconds in but a nice setup
takes that away from Paul Mary that's being
in the right place there's the Ricochet off
the crossb mean I'd love to be in a slump he
still have six goals this part of the season but
for the on dry CLE his expectations are a little
higher there's a defensive play made down low at
the last second by McDavid locked in with soken
boilers Islanders short side feed picked off and
cleared by Nelson Eng ball striding in against
that cor Bard did not clear it Ang ball Point
Blank and that was speared by Skinner position
there Ang ball looking for his first first goal of
the Season here he was a healthy scratch against
the Bruins and then played his season High last
game against Washington L's been effective it's
a big line with Nelson engal Paul the outlet on
target for Sam G busting down the left side and
ilas soken holding Sway and keeping this game tied
at one Rogers Monday night hockey G Foil by S that
place at the right time to s five straight 20
goal campaigns when he was with the New Jersey
doubles around Nelson wait fires up near
the mass get her fought it offner here
on this shot by Nelson as he tries to go
up you see that a lot nowaday trying to
aim bulldo is his way in doson beaten by hman
shot short side throk in H [Applause] above
the goal line it remains tied at one he's had
four good looks from in tight and then here's
the second one Heyman just throws this into soken
follows it up that little [__] at the end the
HS didn't like too much as he jams into the pad
and I to put it back door for CeCe kept alive for
the moment and then steered to the corner by
angul McDavid pounces heads to the middle of
the ice fire srup to the save and G Deni on the
rebound initially tied up by angal this line they
starting to find that chemistry Conor mcdave with
a hard shot good defense to deny in tight Oilers
I mean their power play been criticized it's
still respectable 24% ninth in the league off
the draw buard dishing off new jov get one timer
dyle that this reat scores Dr Conor McDavid and
end first lead of the night two to one they snap
this Puck around and this is a great onetime by
Leon dyell I mean he gets all of this thing and
there's been some Fanning lately didn't fan on
that one but that onetime on the beautiful feed
across sets everything in motion and this little
chip here by McDavid after the blast my dve silent
funnel into the net and it's h that bashes this
one home for a 2-1 lead and they talked about
this all year won The Face Off back to EV finds
Newen Hopkins a dangerous short handed here's
new get stuffed by save made by sokin almost
a similar situation the way it's set up you can
see Bard again taking to the right puts it back
to Newan Hopkins but this time the Islanders are
like we've seen that pretty quickly take that team
away this time they go low to himman and good job
by soken to Snuff that has kept it alive whipped
on that save from dist chunk flber buck and then
what a beautiful stretch here's McDavid off the
watch trickles home SRO can beat and McDavid
gets one to go in 31 hon a watch just he knows
McDavid yelled he wanted it right to the far blue
line and he shoots this puck gets a little bit of
a balance I know Cassie talked about it in the
opening they're not getting a lot of Puck lock
they've created their Puck luck in this one
and they get a little bit of a bounce right
there on Conor McDavid golden to go up by two on
a beautiful transitional play well both McDavid
and dry CLE have had their fair share of hard L
is able to feel a redirection flawlessly here com
the Oilers three on two tries to behind and he's
in heok and he'll squeeze at the top of the blue
paint but now the Oilers flooding their way into
The Islander Zone and now soken will head for the
bench starting to wind down the time a little
bit exactly you're down to 2 and 1/2 minutes
caught off by dry CLE net is empty amander
Kan gets inside the a a blue line and he'll
score for the open neck from far away
why would I get your feet moving work
all the way to the end and tap that popped in
grind it away for 12 years as a head coach two
years as an NHL assistant and he wins his NHL
debut as head coach of the erson ERS 4 to one